race my case you want to do it oh let's
do it I want to do it we get a racism
yes because let's make a show out of it
so for this segment we research some odd
crimes and we're just gonna give you the
description of the crime and like the
headlines and you guys are just gonna
have to talk it out and guess
don't cheat chin chin cheating already
and is it current crimes or like don't
give me old [ __ ]
what do you mean their crimes I wish I
did know the only crimes happen in LA
today oh they want to be fun yeah he's
not I just do carjacking so whole time
you think he's a cop this is a great
note for next time but these are old
okay I probably know you probably know a
lot of them let's go number one
police arrested a 24 year old company
employee for smearing his own excrement
on a girl I feel like it is off
immediately it comes to wake up but I
don't know a lot of different kind of
Orient traditions from the Orient and
that's where I want to go to chin seems
like he has intel on this or I see him
nodding his head
I just piggyback on this because I have
seen some interesting porn in my day
where when it comes to [ __ ] the Asians
partake and what they call I'm sorry
scab pains so it could be Asian or white
uh what is it called white for five
thousand out what scat babes oh you had
to make it why do they do that you can't
just poop enough smell in Asia or so
just get really nasty there's just
they've done everything they want to get
as nasty as possible I mean Japanese by
the way okay
Jarrah Playboy so he's going Japanese
Chan's going Japanese Derek wouldn't
what do you have yeah I'm gonna go ahead
Korean because if there was also a level
of woman shaming and the guys running
one on a woman there's a level of I'm a
man great men hate women
yeah right if you guys need another
sentence let me know we have Noah
someone may have said the correct one
already
is there a quote no quote but on
December 5th at 9:45 p.m. Blanc used a
bicycle to come up from behind the girl
aged in her late teens at an
intersection why dude bye agent Asia all
of Asia not America bro and this
happened in America I'm assuming dude
can I get a place in time I'm not giving
any locations or names can you give me
the Greek name he's in a sentence
blankly who is the dollar in calm down
admit to the allegations telling police
that the extra mint was indeed his own
hello yeah that's a white dude being
like [ __ ] you [ __ ] I don't know I feel
like a white guy would use somebody
else's [ __ ] you know that's all we do is
take other people's [ __ ] yeah there you
go
so I think we would use somebody else's
dung or whatever they call a fee see to
pull off the crime now if there's a
white guy using other people's [ __ ] he'd
be in like a FUBU Jersey and listen to
hip-hop this just the dude
straight up white dude [ __ ] upset
probably I'm cheating on them quick [ __ ]
so much sorry dude
so a Brandon's final answer is white
Theo nice and I'm gonna go we need
specification okay just Asia I'm gonna
go uh I'm gonna go Koreans the dark
Japanese and we do know we're conflating
a little bit nationality and race but it
makes the game better the answer is what
did we lock it oh good catch I'm gonna
say white dude cuz Asians will only do
that if it's consensual and and Asians
only do that if they have an erection
cats on the side I feel like when first
48 we're true detectives what do you got
Nick Derek what was your final I want
three awkward word
the answer is Asian / Japanese it did
happen in Japan God oh that makes so
much sense that makes so much my baked
summer sensei
they do play with the [ __ ]
they do play with the shampoo quit
saying it so much all right they do play
with the feces there you go man Asians
in their own country play by a whole
different set of rules
apparently then boys then boys are
freaky they take it over the top I've
seen some awful stuff yeah
i-i've never seen any that you don't
want it brother
I don't want to and that's why don't
take it into my life if you want to ruin
your date scat babes
no no college dude solid yeah a lot of
time on our hands
someone brought it no there's a lot of
time on their hands in college people
who aren't doing well it costs to go to
college we're playing football and watch
ask a baby
and winning football games all right
what else yet number-two man arrested
for allegedly allegedly throwing a
three-foot live alligator into a Wendy's
drive-thru window this uh was this bliss
it was this juvenile who did this the
rapper
this sounds like specifically one of the
big timers what do you know he was 23
okay okay this in America could be am i
right Nick I can't ask that do we well
what do we do we get a me yeah if you
need more sentences he pull the 22 year
old man had pulled up to grab his order
and a server handed him a drink when the
order when the worker turned around the
man allegedly reached into the back of
his truck and threw the alligator
through the open window now hold on no
you said truck okay alligator check the
the soft drink we speak of you just kind
of blink if I'm on to something
was it a sprite do they say what kind
they do not diet coke this is white boy
all day sprite he's through a [ __ ]
yeah ball into them yeah if it was
double grape was orange soda Brendan I'm
gonna go for me he reaches in the back
of a truck has a nap
have an alligator back there this sounds
very white or Vietnamese to me yeah this
is white as it gets truck
alligators I'm going honky on this one
they do honk honk all day do you know
what the fast food was Wendy's voice
that's everybody loves one day you know
dude there check the nice burger the
fries nuts the spicy nuggets get that
10-piece barbecue sauce you get a frosty
square burgers all day
chicken sandwich okay comater they have
one in Santa Monica
oh yeah Wendy's yeah a lot of people
know over there on 7th and uh Santa
Monica Boulevard
everybody loves Wendy so except that
doesn't help you use in a sentence again
was the employee black or white or Asian
or do we know what the employee race was
we didn't get details on the victim any
JPEG okay good call all right I'm
locking in man I'm going white how big
was the alligator three feet you could
tie that around your foot and say it's a
shoot I don't know why this is news
something he's given my gift
buddy stoked if someone to a [ __ ]
alligator oh thanks dude raised as well
well that's a churro in Vietnam dude a
foot alligator gang [ __ ] I'm gonna go
white all day I'm white white white
white dude from Florida mmm why dude cat
with the bonus point he was Floridian
white man [ __ ] chin you'd even guess
Wow yeah I don't participate your own
life that's good
macho life pass by chin okay yeah so cat
gets that bonus point man dude all right
give us one more time last one
man urinates in Walmart as he puts trout
in his pants
wait how was he doing both yeah man was
arrested after a urinated Walmart we're
trying to put a package of trout in his
trousers and then told police officer
that he wasn't concerned because his
crimes were only misdemeanors
there's nothing wider than trout it was
1:30 on a Wednesday what there in the
afternoon I think it's the city in this
one it's Walmart yes do we do we want to
give the city I can't give the city if
we need more might as well you want the
city Theo city of what we're this walled
city of God Brazil he also said he was
had been consuming alcohol mm-hmm and
what he's hiding trout he's hiding a
package trout's a frozen trout these are
not live trout who that would make me
urine and I think if you go the whole
frozen trout straight to your wiener
area for a couple trout he's near my
pelvis and try to pretend like you
didn't that's the hard part then that's
where you shock your nervous system in a
urinating but stealing Troutman which
it's cheap yeah things are rough dude he
knew was a misdemeanor so he knows he's
been through this he's been through the
system before yeah this just sounds like
somebody who's just out there you know
like they just happened to pick up
anything it happened to be trowel black
no white wire buddy he knows the system
too well to misdemeanor it something
maybe somebody's like salmon that
trout's cheap as [ __ ] here we go like
maybe he's trying to go to jail like
maybe he's trying to maybe he knows if
he gets caught it's like doing you know
it's tip for stealing [ __ ] crab you
can't take away your right to vote for a
misdemeanor right yeah I'll go black
I'll go black as well just because I've
already done some of the other
I can only say white so many times I
think I Hazen again
yeah I think no Korean or Chinese
Walmart yeah so if I don't Nick it's not
a black guy another Korean I just I
would if I here's the thing if I had to
watch somebody do it honestly I'd like
to watch a black guy do it I think
that's why honestly because they would
do it in the most fun way agree you know
this man was from Clarksville Tennessee
and he was black wow that was a cold
case is the coldest case is frozen cold
cold case baby I did think about as a
[ __ ] it's doing three white people yes
be hilarious and I probably am alright
but it's good to know that everybody's
doing crime and it's good to know that
uh that's the important part
yeah buddy's doing race Marquesa who won
I think I think Kat to do that bonus
point about the Florida one yep like I
said I think that's more of a gift
awesome so in a three foot alligator hmm
it's a lot of smart Billy but when
you're at work I think give it to him
when they leave a work you know yeah you
know to drive through orders and
somebody [ __ ] throws a new pet at you
that sounds drastic all right dude let's
get this bus on the highway what do we
have going on today son fun game though
guys that was race my case if you guys
have a couple can they submit them uh
yeah I would love that if you submit
them just include all the information as
many details as possible and definitely
try to specify highlight the race so we
go cuz that's fun yeah there's a lot of
fun crime crime has no happens man crime
has no color that's true I think that's
what we learned guys
[Laughter]
back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching
you